hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast on mobility mass spectrometry
in the omics presented by Christian art
assistant professor of chemistry
department of biomedical and chemical
engineering and Sciences Florida
Institute of Technology I'm Alexis
Krause of leopard's
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before you begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want but anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and type your
question into the drop down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
answer well respond to your questions
via email if you're trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Jannard I will now turn the presentation
over to him thank you for the
introduction Alexis today we're going to
be talking about a tandem technique
which is ion mobility spectrometry
coupled with mass spectrometry and
especially for its use in the biological
omics being metabolomics lipid omics and
proteomics and so i'd like to start off
today by going through some of the very
basics of ion mobility spectrometry this
is a technique that's been around for
several decades now but has actually
just really come into vogue for omics
studies over the last couple of decades
thanks in part to some very fundamental
research that's been performed as well
as a broad scale commercialization of
this technique with ion mobility
spectrometry it's a separation technique
based on gas phase I
as they move electrofield the original
and the most basic form of ion mobility
spectrometry is a constant field or
what's referred to as a drift tube I am
mobility spectrometer and this is the
general diagram that you see here on
your screen however it's important to
note that there are several different
flavors so to speak of ion mobility
spectrometry another one that's been
used for several decades now is what's
referred to as high field asymmetric
wave form ion mobility spectrometry
sometimes referred to as
fames but you may also see this referred
to as differential mobility spectrometry
or DMS such as with the Sai X alexion
platform and in this particular type of
technique rather than having a constant
field we actually have an alternating
field where we go between a high field
as you can see in the pink in a low
field which is applied in the gray for a
slightly longer period of time there and
what this actually does is the ions will
move between electrodes depending on
differences in their high field and
their low field mobility x' another more
recent advent is called the traveling
wave or TW IMS and this was first
invented by watters corporation over a
decade ago and this was really the first
big commercialization of ion mobility
spectrometry now unlike with a constant
field drift tube type device this
actually uses electrodes that undergo a
dynamic field where you can see these
waves that slowly move through the drift
tube and ions depending on their
mobility while either ride on the front
of these waves or roll over and so the
higher mobility ions will move more
quickly as they ride on the waves
whereas the lower mobility ions will be
inclined to roll over more frequently
and arrive at the detector at a later
time
now with drift - by mobility which is
pretty of what I'll talk about today as
I said the ions are pulsed into the
drift tube with a constant electric
field so you can see over there on the
Left where it says ions enter the drift
tube a packet of ions
a spatial and temporal packet that's
narrowly confined are pulsed into an
electric field drift tube which is kept
in a constant electric field and these
ions will experience collisions with
drift gas molecules within the tube and
are separated ultimately based on
differences in their size shape and
charge now it's important to note that
unlike with mass spectrometry that many
of you may be aware of in which we do
measurements at a high vacuum ion
mobility actually makes use of the
collisions between our analytes of
interest and our buffer gas molecules so
this is done at either an intermediate
pressure of around a few tor all the way
up to atmospheric pressure now with
these collisions smaller ions will
experience fewer collisions and so
they'll travel at a higher velocity
whereas larger ions will have more
collisions and will go more slowly now
this is important to note that this is
not just based on the mass of the ions
this has to do with the overall size
which could be is the same ion that
might be in a more compact or more
elongated form which would result in
different mobilities now with ion
mobility what we're actually measuring
is a drift time at a detector this is
the amount of time it takes from start
to finish and based on the length of a
drift tube which you can see here is L
divided by a drift time we can calculate
the actual drift velocity for any given
iya but what we really are interested is
this mobily factor k and based on the
drift velocity calculated from the drift
time we can use that in conjunction with
the electric field that we apply across
the drift tube to calculate this
mobility factor you'll also often see
this referred to as K sub zero or K
naught which just takes into account
factors such as your standard
temperature and pressure and this is the
way that you would account for those
using this equation here in the bottom
right so the basic mobility concept here
is that if you take two different ions
and in this particular case we have
fatty acids that have one double bond in
the middle of
that chain and one of those double bonds
is in the sis configuration and the
other is in the trans configuration now
using something like a mass spectrometer
what you'd find is that the
mass-to-charge the MZ would be exactly
the same and you might not be able to
differentiate between these two but you
can tell from the diagram on the left
that they have very different structures
and so as you pulse these through the
drift tube you'll find that they move at
very different drift velocities and
ultimately as we put up a spectrum a
drift time or arrival time spectrum
you'd see that they'd have very
different arrival times and the heights
of these Peaks can actually be used to
represent the relative intensities of
these two now one of the ideal
advantages to using ion mobility is the
way that it nests with other commonly
used analytical techniques so many of
you will be familiar with using things
like chromatography LLC GC either even
things like supercritical fluid
chromatography now these kind of
separations take course over the span of
several minutes or even with longer
proteomics analyses several hours and
with that I bread raised that we're able
to easily nest ion mobility because
these spectra are acquired on the order
of a few milliseconds anywhere from five
up to about a hundred milliseconds
depending on the type of ion mobility
instrumentation your music and so with
these were able to for each given LC
peak were able to get several ion
mobility spectrum a spectrometer like a
time of flight or Tov instrument where
we're acquiring data on the order of
about a hundred microseconds were then
able to generate individual mass spectra
for each one of these ion mobility piece
so in this particular case where we have
two very similar mobility Peaks we're
actually able to tell if there are
differences in their mass to charge or
if they're similar
they could be isomers now this is a very
simple thing that you will have seen in
any of your analytical chemistry courses
where we take hyphenated techniques and
by adding several stages of analysis
we're actually able to
signal-to-noise so by going from a
single stage like an LC or GC or even a
mass spectrum and coupling those
together in step two here we go to lcms
and in step three we go to LC with
tandem mass spec but by further into
implementing the step of ion mobility in
here what were effectively doing is
reducing the chemical noise even further
and although the signal does go down by
a little bit the signal-to-noise ratio
is still going up and so we can we can
get better and more confident
identification of techniques based on
this hyphenated method so for those of
you that are visually inclined here I've
included a diagram of an ion mobility
mass spectrometer with a time-of-flight
mass analyzer up here on the back end
now you can see a few ions that are
trapped here in the bottom left corner
right before the ion mobility drift cell
now because what we're actually
measuring is the amount of time that it
takes from start to finish we have to
trap these ions in a very small temporal
region some kind of a trapping area and
as soon as we hit start analogous to
runners in a race when you might have a
starter's pistol go off you'll actually
see the ions that will then move through
the drift cell at various velocities and
ultimately be analyzed using the mass
spectrometer this allows us to get to
characteristic pieces of information for
every ayah the first that you'll see on
the y-axis in this diagram here in the
top left is the drift time and that's
the amount of time it takes for the ions
to get from start to the end which is
the mass spec detector the second is
because we are using a mass spectrometer
or able to get the master charge value
for all of these ions as well and this
allows us to create these characteristic
three-dimensional plots of drift time
versus mass to charge that gives us an
extra dimension of separation in
contrast to traditional mass spec that
just has the one now when we also couple
this with something like tandem mass
spectrometry
something like a cue Tov mass
spectrometer we can also isolate a given
ion and fragment in the collision cell
or we could just sell out all of the
ions to collide and in that particular
case we were doing all ion fragmentation
we're able to line up our precursor ions
with our parent with our fragment ions
because this is happening after the I a
mobility drift cell and as such all of
the ions regardless of how they're
fragmented will have the same drift time
so you could you see here a peak with
the master charge of 6:23 is being
fragmented down to a master charge of
402 but it still remains with the same
drift time because this is happening
after the ion mobility cell and so this
is really helpful in being able to line
up your precursor and your fragment ions
after a mobility separation now I am
mobility has several other advantages
and one of them is that we do get that
additional separation of components and
complex mixtures so if we take something
like chromatic here we have several
peaks we may also see that we can get
things like Co alluding compounds that
are isobaric or isomeric and in this
particular example we have this one peak
just after five minute retention time
and if we look at the mass spectrum
there we only see one primary peak
however if we go further and we look at
the ion mobility spectrum we now see
that there's actually two distinct peaks
with very different drift times and what
this is is actually stereoisomers that
have the exact same mass to charge Co
aleut chromatographic Li but are
resolved when we use ion mobility
measurements now we can take the
measurement of drift time and calculate
the mobility factor k but we can also
take it one step further into this
parameter that we refer to as a
collision cross-section or CCS and this
is useful for identification because we
can couple it with a retention time
library and amass charge database and we
can form these large libraries that will
allow us to identify unknowns and so I
have an unknown steroid where I should
say a known star right here in prim
minimum with a drift time and using this
equation which is a modified version of
the mason shop equation which takes into
account several different experimental
parameters things like the drift to
temperature the gas that we're using the
buffer gas which we put in terms of the
reduced mass as well as the electric
field the length of the drift tube and
actually the drift tube pressure which
we also refer to in terms of the number
density or the number of upper gas
molecules we have per unit of volume and
so with these cross section values which
are important to note that these cross
section values are dependent on these
temperatures these pressures as well as
the actual type of ion mobility you're
doing whether it be a simple drift tube
static field measurement or something
like a traveling wave measurement it is
important that these values can differ
based on those conditions and so you
should always mention what conditions
you're using to determine a particular
collision cross section and with those
collision cross sections you can see
here that if we create those three
dimensional plots of CCS or drift time
versus mass-to-charge we can then match
those based on those two different
values and we see that we get a distinct
a dramatic reduction in our false
positive rate when we combine those two
and so when we go one step further by
using both chromatography as well as
tandem mass spec our confidence and
identification goes up dramatically and
this goes down to a false positive rate
of nearly zero which is in some cases
even better than using very high
resolution mass spec such as with
Orbitrap based platforms or FG IC are
based platforms now it's also important
to note that in addition to being a very
useful separation technique and mobility
also gives some relative structural
information for gas phase molecules or
gas phase complexes and we can look at
things like binding strength or overall
complex size and we can also look at the
way that these interact within an ion
mobility spectrometer based on the
energy that we impart on those so you
might imagine that in a case where we
have two different isomeric ions that
may have different confirmations or
different structures while a mass
spectrometer might not allow us to
differentiate between these two because
their structures are different we can in
theory separate them using ion mobility
so I want to start off by talking a
little bit about chemical biology and
the omics
and how I and mobility mass spec can
help with these particular things now
you're all very familiar with this
diagram where we go from our genetic
information in our body through the
transcriptome creating proteins and
ultimately creating metabolites which
influence our phenotype now these things
are also influenced by outside factors
such as our microbiome as well as our
environment or our expose oh but while
we have genomics transcriptomics and
proteomics that are very much closer to
the genetic makeup of our bodies
the metabolomics or the metabolites
within our body are much closer to the
actual phenotype and so this is one of
the reasons why metabolomics has become
one of the more popular omics Sciences
over the last decade however
metabolomics is actually not new and
here we have what is the urine wheel
that was first published in Tino's where
scientists and physicians would actually
look at the color the viscosity and even
in some cases the taste of urine to help
diagnose in diseases and fortunately for
us we have instrumentation like mass
spectrometers and I a mobility
spectrometers that allow us to analyze
our samples so that we don't have to
taste and smell urine or other
biological samples anymore now when
we're looking at ion mobility mass spec
spectrum we tend to get these
conformational ordering of biomolecules
that allows us to further identify
unknown types of samples so what you'll
see here on the left is a plot of a
number of different compounds some
standards that we use these are tetra
alkyl ammonium salts as well as other
common biological molecules such as
lipids peptides and carbohydrates and
here on the right what you'll see is
that these separate out into these
individual bands such that if you had an
unknown with a given collision cross
section and mass-to-charge you might be
able to place that unknown molecule into
a given band and have more confidence in
saying I think that this might be a
carbohydrate based on the collision
cross section and mass-to-charge
combination so let's take a look at
some actual examples of instances where
I in mobility can help us to separate
things so here we have a couple of
steroids pregnant alone and 5-alpha
dihedral progesterone and these are
intermediates in the biosynthetic allo
pregnenolone
pathway and we see that the structures
for these like many steroids are very
similar however when we look at them
with an ion mobility spectrometer were
able to tell them apart and they have
collision cross-sections that differ by
quite a bit you see a collision cross
section there and angstroms squared of
about 176 for pregnenolone
versus 191 for 5-alpha dihedral
progesterone and again I've highlighted
here in red the structural differences
between these two because they are very
subtle the pregnenolone on the left has
a hydroxyl group whereas the 5 alpha dhp
has a ketone group there and there's
also the presence of a double bond and
Prime minutes absent in its isomer
counterpart now the separation between
these two the resolution is about one
point two three so this is nearly
baseline resolve for these compounds
that are not able to be distinguished
with single stage mass spectrometry and
also would require chromatography
extended chromatography to be able to
separate them now here's a number of
other examples of common biological
steroids these are all isomer pairs that
you would require extended
chromatography in some cases tandem mass
spec will be able to separate these but
for a lot of stereoisomers things like
testosterone and EPI testosterone down
here in the bottom left corner
these actually can't be differentiated
with mass spectrometry but I am ability
allows you to baseline resolve all of
these compounds now another thing to
note with these particular ion mobility
spectra that I'm showing conventional or
commercially available types of
instrumentation still have an inherent
lack of resolution or or a limit on the
ability to separate very structurally
similar compounds and so throughout this
talk I'll be making mention of a few
different examples of strategies that we
can use to
to further augment the separation and so
I'm showing an example here where we
have a few more endogenous steroids
testosterone dehydroepiandrosterone or
DHEA
and epi testosterone and you see here
that we separate these with a drift tube
I a mobility spectrometer we see that
the testosterone is well resolved but
the other two compounds are essentially
overlapping we're not able to resolve
one from the other however when we
change over to a different drift gas in
this particular case the spectrum was
acquired with a nitrogen drift gas which
has become the most popular choice
because it's fairly cost effective and
it's also readily available when we
switch over to another drift gas
something that might be larger more
polarizable like carbon dioxide we see
that these compounds start to resolve
now this is certainly not a universal
trend where we see moving between drift
gases will always improve separation
between isomers but it can be very
helpful in particular particularly
tricky situations like the one I've
shown here we can apply this to a lot of
other types of omics compounds here I've
shown different types of bile acid
isomers and you can see the only
difference between these between the one
on the left and the one at the top is
the difference in position of one
hydroxyl group and between the bottom
two the GC DCA
as well as the GU DCA the only
difference between these is the
stereochemistry of one hydroxyl group so
these are structurally very similar
compounds but when we use high
resolution ion mobility spectrometry
we're actually able to separate these
out quite well in this particular
analysis was done using a very high
resolution ion mobility spectrometer
which is called the structures for
lossless ion manipulations or slim
platform and I'll talk about that just a
little bit later we can also look at
things that have quite a bit of
structural diversity things like glycans
where we may have isomers that include
different monomer
sub-units like galactose glucose and
mannose we may also have different types
of connectivity such as alpha 1 6 vs
alpha one four linkages or beta 1-4
linked with linkages and again the
structural complexity of these becomes a
little bit confusing and because of that
I a mobility can be a really useful tool
because these structural differences
allow us as you can see over here on the
right this technique allows us to
separate these compounds fairly
routinely now I talked about
conformational ordering of biomolecules
based on differences in their class but
I also mentioned earlier that I am
mobility allows separation based on size
shape and charge and so what you'll
notice is if you're looking at a very
complicated mixture like a phosphatidyl
ethanolamine mixture here that we've
shown in terms of drift time versus
their mass we actually see these
characteristic bands based on their
charge whereas the lowest mobility ions
the plus ones will be any much later
drift time relative to their mass the +
2 + 3 + +4 ions will have a higher
mobility we can look at things like
fatty acids and I showed a very brief
example during my introduction where we
looked at the difference between assists
and trans double bond but we can also
look at differences in the placement of
double bonds and so here I've shown the
comparison of a fatty acid a saturated
fatty acid 18 : 0 in comparison with
fatty acids that have a double bond at
either the 9 position or at the 11
position and those that differ as well
in the sis and trans configuration and
here you can see that all four of these
different isomers the sis and trans 11
in system trans 9 are also separated
from the saturated 18 : 0 fatty acid
here and we're able to resolve all four
of these compounds using ion mobility we
can look at other types of lipid
structural differences things like
differences in the sn1 sn2
configuration as shown on the left where
the tails are actually swapped on the
head group we can also look at
differences in the actual backbone or
the head group on these lipids or two
different things that might be isobaric
or isomeric will have very different gas
phase structures and can be separated
with ayam ability and as I said we can
separate differences in things like sis
and trans orientation as well as in the
snr configuration on the actual where
the head tail group meets the head so i
want to go into a little bit of a deep
detail about a cool story that we had
while I was at the University of Florida
giving Dean metabolites and the
importance of a particular set of
epimers or the c3 epimers now vitamin D
the analysis for vitamin D deficiency is
actually one of the top clinically run
assays or one of the most popular
clinical acts in the entire country and
this is especially important in infant
and pediatric as well as in pregnant
populations but it's important to note
that these have been identified even in
normal adult populations and so being
able to differentiate between these
isomers is important now what you'll see
here on the right is the structure for
25 hydroxy vitamin d3 which is the most
common target analyte in vitamin D
deficiency assays but at the bottom
you'll notice that it also has a
hydroxyl group epimer 3 epi 25 hydroxy
d3 and that's the only structural
difference between these two is the
stereochemistry of that hydroxyl group
whether it's alpha or beta to the ring
now this epimer down here at the bottom
has been shown to have reduced calcium
regulation and has also been has also
been shown that it may have some some
kind of effect on different types of
cancers but many lc-ms methods do not
differentiate between these epimers and
as structural isomers mass spectrometry
even tend a mass spec cannot
differentiate between these two and
although chromatography can it can be a
longer
Photography run that's not always ideal
for a clinical analysis where you want
to have runs that are down as low as two
minutes and time now because they're
often not differentiating between these
two the overall results are what you're
getting for a 25 hydroxy vitamin d3
concentration can be positively biased
because you're actually adding the sum
of two different compounds now there's
also a higher ionization efficiency for
the former which further biases the
results but I am mobility is a potential
improvement in that based on differences
in the structure for these two we should
be able to separate them and what we've
shown here is that for the common mass
spectrometry ion which is the M plus h
minus water unfortunately these two do
not separate very well but another
strategy that we can use to further
separate things that are very
structurally similar is to look at
different types of ion atoms so here
we're looking at just a protonated water
loss addict but we can also look at
things like sodium or even potassium
ions and so here I've shown the two
epimers in orange and blue for 25
hydroxy vitamin d3 as well as the plant
derived source of vitamin D which is 25
hydroxy vitamin D 2 and when we look at
the ion mobility expect spectra for
these we actually see that they're
fairly similar in collision
cross-section
certainly not baseline resolved by any
means but if we look out a little bit
further in the drift time spectrum we
noticed this one peak here that's
present only for 25 hydroxy d3 and at a
larger at a later drift time we know
that this corresponds to some kind of
larger structure and this is where I'm
ability helps us to terminus now when we
look at the mass spectrum for each of
these individual Peaks this additional
drift peak that's unique to 25 hydroxy
d3 in comparison with this primary peak
that's seen here around
25 to 26 milliseconds we know that via
mass spectrum denoted here by a and B is
exactly the same this is just the Saudi
ated 25 hydroxy D 3 or epi 25 hydroxy D
3 so why do we have that extra peak
there at B and why is it only present
for one of the two compounds well a
further strategy in addition to looking
at different types of ion addicts it's
actually used theoretical modeling which
has made leaps and bounds and helping to
look at gas phase structure for
biomolecules and so if we go back to the
structure for 25 hydroxy D 3 shown here
we really have two different locations
where the sodium can form the ion one is
on this C 3 hydroxyl group down here in
the bottom left and the other is this
tail group hydroxyl group up here in the
top right however we also have a
potential third option where because of
the structural flexibility of 25 hydroxy
vitamin D 3 which is a Seco steroid
which means that that B ring on your
normal steroid structure has actually
been cleaved we can actually have this
bend around such that the sodium ion is
interacting with both hydroxyl groups at
the same time and in doing theoretical
modeling we show that indeed this is the
lowest energy conformation structure is
with this vitamin D analyte and what we
call the closed
con for me now our theoretical or the
cross section that we get through
theoretical modeling matches very
closely with that that we figure out
experimentally and so we know that this
is a good candidate for our structure
however from our theoretical modeling we
also notice that there's another local
minima which is that only a slightly
higher energy and this is one of those
cases that I noted before where maybe
the sodium ion is interacting with only
one hydroxyl group or the other in this
particular case we're showing the
structure where it's interacting with
the C 3 hydroxyl group and when we look
at energy diagrams for 25 hydroxy D 3 we
note that the difference in energy
between that close and open conformation
is only about 2 K Cal's per mole
so this is an energetically accessible
conformation these two different
converse however when we look at the
same thing for the epimer the EPI 25
hydroxy d3 we see that that difference
in energy is much larger at about 10 K
Cal's per mole and this is energetically
inaccessible such that while the 25
hydroxy d3 can adopt both of those
different confirmations the epimer will
only adopt one of them and so if we go
back to our original spectrum where we
see two different Peaks and a unique
peak for 25 hydroxy d3 we're actually
able to conclude that this is a result
of a different gas phase structure this
open or more elongated version of 25
hydroxy d3 and so the reason that this
is important is for two reasons one I am
ability in conjunction with the
theoretical modeling actually can give
us information on differences in the gas
phase structure and one of those
differences actually me and furthermore
because these two compounds adopt very
different structures we're able to
separate them such that we could do
something like an LC I MMS analysis and
actually give quantitative results for
just 25 hydroxy D 30 without being
biased by etcetera so we're gonna shift
gears here a little bit and talk about
another version of the omics
specifically in this case we're talking
about proteomics now proteomics is a
huge field and in many ways it's a
little bit more complicated than small
molecule metabolomics or lipid omics and
if we take a particular protein
something like retinol binding protein
one that's shown here this is a huge
molecule in much different to analyze in
comparison with some of the smaller
vitamins or lipids that i've shown
previously now generally speaking we
split proteomics up into a couple of
different fields we could talk about
top-down clinics this is analysis of
intact proteins so as these very large
tens to hundreds even thousands of
killer Dalton proteins and it can be
very challenging experimentally and
often requires her
high resolution mass spectrometry things
like as I mentioned before Orbitrap or
FDIC are based platforms however
something that's much simpler and easier
in terms of an instrumental burden is
what's referred to as bottom-up
proteomics and what we do is we take
these proteins and we actually use some
kind of an enzyme such as trypsin and we
actually cleave these proteins to create
very small sequences very small peptides
and then we can identify these
individual peptides and put them back
together to identify a protein now like
I said this is a much less of an
instrumental burden because we only need
to identify these very small peptides
and it is indeed the most common method
especially for any time any type of
quantitative proteomics but it's
important to note that even when we've
split these up into much smaller
peptides that are easier to analyze we
can deal with things like isomers where
we may have different sequence isomers
where the peptides will have a different
grouping of amino acids but ultimately
will be analyzed and detected at the
same mass-to-charge value we can also
have things like post translational
modifications or PTMs
that might occur at different residues
within the peptides and when we have
that as here in the bond with this
peptide that has two highlighted s
residues in this particular case we
could have a post translational
modification at one group or the other
group but we can't really separate these
using mass spectrometry alone however
they do have very different gas phase
structures so when we take a peptide
like this and we analyze it both with
chromatography here on the Left we show
chromatogram where this particular
peptide elutes at about 45 minutes we
can also look at the mass spectrum but
unfortunately we see the exact same
mass-to-charge value for both of these
peptides and we can't differentiate
between the two
however when we look with
high-resolution ion mobility such as
with the slimming platform that I
previously mentioned were actually able
to differentiate between these two based
on the location of that
translational modification in this
particular case it was a difference in
the location of phosphorylation and so
this is really a prime example of a way
in which ion mobility can go one step
further than your traditional lcms and
even LC ms/ms types of proteomics
analyses and so this is a little bit of
an older example but it really really
captures the power of ion mobility where
if we use these three dimensions of mass
mastercharge retention time
chromatographic retention time and a
drift time we can actually plot these
out in this cool plot here
and also use a heat map for the
intensity the relative intensity of
these features to identify literally
thousands of different features from in
within one proteomics digest and this
significantly increases the number of
features that we can identify in
contrast with just LC and/or ms alone
now in addition to the kinds of
structural information that we can get
for intact proteins or even for
metabolites we can also look at the ways
in which we can probe these with
different amounts of energy to actually
get protein structure in a little bit
more detail so in this diagram on the
top we've taken a protein that has many
of these alpha helixes and overall this
protein is in a fairly compact format
okay and you can see that as a function
of a very short drift time however as we
start to move up from bottom to top
we're increasing the collision voltage
and ultimately imparting more energy on
these proteins and as we do so you'll
start to see some of these regions
actually unfold any long gate and as you
increase the collision voltage even
further you'll see that in the top right
corner there that these these proteins
have become almost completely unfolded
or elongated and based on their ion
mobility drift time they have a much
larger collision cross-section now this
is a technique that's referred to as
collision induced unfolding or CIU
and it creates these plots here at the
ball
whereas a function of collision voltage
we can actually see the ion mobility
drift time increase and we create these
plots where we'll see the characteristic
didn't points between very compact
structures into intermediate and
ultimately into very elongated
structures and we can also tell a little
bit about the energy of that folding
based on how much collision voltage is
required to start to separate these and
to elongate them into the more unfolded
format now I am mobility has really
exploded over the last decade as I said
thanks in part to a very widespread
commercialization in fact the majority
of mass spec vendors that you'll look at
in some shape or form will have their
own types of I am ability that can
couple with their mass spectrometers and
these include things like traditional
drift tube IMS a traveling wave IMS as
well as things like fames or
differential mobility spectrometry but
what are some of the directions that we
need to move towards in continuing to
expand upon ims analysis well one of
them is moving towards higher resolution
instrumentation I mentioned before that
a number of the platforms that are
commercially available on the market
still kind of lacked the resolution
necessary to routinely separate very
structurally similar compounds and in
this particular case we can go through
some of the strategies that I that I
hinted at things like using different
cation or anion addict's using different
types of thrift gases to augment the
separation and even using theoretical
modeling to further identify structural
differences however there have also been
a lot of advances in ion mobility
instrumentation and I've named a couple
here tracking ability spectrometry which
is an advanced that's been developed by
Brooker is another type of very high
resolution ion mobility that can give
you a little bit more information than
with other types of commercially
available platforms as well as another
type
my mobility structures for lossless ion
manipulations or the slim platform which
is developed by the Smith group at
Pacific Northwest National Lab and this
is actually a technique that's had some
of the highest recorded
I am ability resolutions in history
furthermore we can also look to couple I
in mobility with higher resolution mass
spectrometers now I've primarily talked
about time-of-flight or top based mass
analyzers and the reason for that is
that ideal time nesting that I showed
very on in the top things like Orbitrap
based platforms do have a much lower
duty cycle and as such it can be
difficult to couple the two in a very
routine manner however there have been
instances of coupling ion mobility drift
tubes with Orbitrap based platforms and
if we can do that with very high
resolution ion mobility then we're
getting really the best of both worlds
or we're getting high-res ion mobility
as well as high-res accurate mass mass
spectrometry measurements next we want
to have more continuity in the
measurements as well as the calibration
for CCS determination and what this
means is unlike with mass spectrometry
where we can publicly the basis of M
over Z values with collision
cross-sections it is very dependent on
the type of conditions in which you're
making the measurements be it the
temperature and pressure the type of ion
mobility you're using being a drift to
or something like a traveling wave
platform we need to have more continuity
in the field in the way that we make the
measurements and also in the types of
standards to calibrate the instruments
we can couple ion mobility and/or mass
spectrometry with further types of
techniques we can do tandem mass spec or
even all iron fragmentation where we're
not discriminating based on a parent ion
but we are fragmenting all of those and
using that characteristic matching of
drift time with parent and daughter ions
as in all ion fragmentation we can also
use spectroscopic techniques things like
UV and IR spectroscopy to actually get
more structural information for
compounds after they've been separated
you
and mobility and finally we can look at
things like gas phase chemistry where we
can do ion ion and I Ambala Kuehl
reactions either to complex some of the
compounds and augment their structural
differences for better separation or to
do some kind of iron molecule
dissociation there's some cool work
that's being done with ozone induced
dissociation that selectively cleaves
that carbon-carbon double bonds this is
especially important for things like
lipid omics where we have a lot of
diversity in the place the location the
configuration and the number of double
bonds present in these types of lipid
isomers we can also look at ion mobility
with a number of different novel
sampling techniques so I am mobility
with imaging is something that's really
just started to creep into the
literature but you can imagine for
imaging things like MALDI or even desi
imaging that lack a type of
pre-separation like a chromatography
using ion mobility because it's so fast
and it's done in the gas phase can
really extend the utility of mass spec
imaging we can also couple this with
ambient ionization as I mentioned things
like desi or even things like rapid
evaporation or reams mass spec like as
in the case of the I knife and we can
get an additional dimension of
separation using ion mobility and
finally I put clinical analysis here
with a question mark and the reason for
this is I and mobility has really yet to
see a routine implementation in the
clinical lab but in fact it's really not
been that long since clinicians readily
adopted the use of LC tandem mass spec
and now it is considered the gold
standard in clinical analysis but I
believe that within the next five to ten
years you will see AI and mobility in
some shape or form become adopted in the
clinical form and really advance the
types of analyses that they can do to
help physician patient relationships so
I'd like to finish by acknowledging
several people
former team at the University of Florida
dr. Rick Yost and dr. adrian royde burg
who helped out with a lot of the
modeling that you've seen here in
today's presentation as well as a few of
the graduate students their Lobby
government and Manisha's Cruzeiro my
other former team at Pacific Northwest
National Lab dr. dick Smith dr. Yehia
Ibrahim and dr. game Maggie
very influential and development of the
slim technology as well as some of the
high resolution
I am ability spectra you saw during
today's talk as well as dr. Aaron Baker
formerly at pnnl now at North Carolina
State University especially for her
insights and some of the I am molecule
reactions as well as the lipid omics and
finally my commercial sponsor agilent
technologies without whom I couldn't do
all of my I am ability research that I
do and so with that I'd be happy to take
any questions from the audience and as
Alexis mentioned any questions that we
don't get to be happy to respond to via
email in the very near future
thank you dr. channard for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left your presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is can I am I'm a
separate in excuse me can i am ms
separate in nancy oma OMERS that's a
very good question so we recall that
enantiomers are mirror images of the
same compound in a lot of cases they
have very different biological
activities you think back to an example
like thalidomide back from the 50s and
60s where these two enantiomers actually
had dramatically different effects on
pregnant women and ultimately on the
children that they
and with enantiomers unfortunately their
collision cross-sections because they
are exact mirror images their collision
cross-sections unless their mobilities
are identical so as parent compound
interest cannot be separated with ion
mobility however there are some caveats
to that in that if you're able to
complex enantiomers with some kind of
chiral reagent there have been numerous
studies in the literature where this is
a strategy that does enable separation
of enantiomers although it's by no means
universal it's definitely still in its
infancy in terms of really developing
strategies to routinely separate
enantiomers now our next question how
can resolution of structurally similar
compounds be improved so like I said
there's two main ways that we can
improve upon resolution of structurally
similar compounds obviously we can go to
higher resolution ion mobility platforms
things that I mentioned like trapped ion
mobility and even the slim platform
develop at piano but if we don't have
access to those if we have a lot of
other commercial types of drift tube or
traveling wave instruments we can do
things to modify the chemistry of our
compounds and this includes things like
derivatives a ssin which is a commonly
used strategy with chromatography as
well we can derivatized to augment
structural differences we can also use
different types of complexing agents or
cation or anion addicts using things
rather than just simple protonation or
so d--ation
we can go to larger types of ions other
alkali or alkaline earth metals there
have even been cases where transition
metals are used to change the structure
enough to be able to separate
structurally similar things and in some
cases using different drift gases like
carbon dioxide even sulfur hexafluoride
has been shown in the literature to
improve some of the separation for
structurally similar compounds and it
looks like we have time for one more
question what are the major barriers to
routine implementation of
a mess in clinical settings so with
clinical analysis we're thinking about a
lot of figures of Merit like sensitivity
or specificity and the speed and the
cost and so the point at which I am
ability mass spec really benefits the
clinicians in terms of those different
figures of Merit is where they'll start
to adopt this technique regularly so
with sensitivity remember that we're
doing most of these analyses using a
time-of-flight mass spectrometer which
is really not the most ideal
quantitative platform so we can see
instrumental advances where we're using
other types of mass spec to be more
sensitive and to give better limits of
detection in terms of specificity we're
certainly gaining more information and
better confidence and identification
we're using ion mobility and speed is
certainly not an issue because this
nests very well with L CMS which is
really the gold standard in clinical
analysis right now and finally in terms
of cost as these instruments become more
readily available and more easy to
manufacture certainly the cost of the
instruments will come down and that will
mean the cost per analysis for
clinicians will also be decreased and so
ultimately it's my belief that within
the next five to ten years you will
really see a routine implementation of I
am ability mass spect in clinical
settings I would like to once again
think doctors should not for his
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through January of 2019
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again soon goodbye